okay next game with some molten
international master from australia
since this australia right australia i
am oh we've got a catalan my place this
line became Queen d6s a surreal move
that son yeah it's my backup line
because I don't know much about them
about 96 which is my father the most
popular move but people usually don't
know Queen d6 very low so my results are
not not bad this already looks quite ok
I think cannot take now because of the
exchange on d1 and the night is hanging
so now I could actually win a pawn on d4
unless he's got some some tricks IAM
with the back rank or something i just i
take it I don't think so
and the polar is always pretty high
rated close to 2,600 here in the
five-minute pool this is some pretty
pretty high rating okay still I have
this this extra pawn I could just
develop this with them there should be
seven of course but this might return
the pawn
I need to get some development going
here not sure how else I should develop
the c8 bishop yeah it doesn't it doesn't
take it usually white get this pawn back
anyway okay maybe is it an idea to play
and not before where does he does he go
then I was thinking about 94 now 94
maybe maybe this is an idea actually
provoke b3 and then I dropped the bishop
back now 94 would walk into a pin which
he nevertheless place quickly ok the
idea with provoking be three words of
costume to get square on c3 this should
be four with my attention and then
Knight c3 isn't this a good a good
position and it also went further time
with rook c8 in case he goes to the C
file yeah now this one
yeah of course but now queen bee 6 + d 4
D 491 are hanging if you would have
moved the rock I could have found
captured and before this gets pretty
complicated now 2583 ago Queen a6 the
effort has a discovery
I don't I don't have many squats
available maybe this wasn't a good idea
after all look the tractor if I think
hmm i don't see how i should avoid
losing material now who very strange
yes simply if no move a 3
I three just wins now I think
or at least should be it doesn't play it
okay I probably am seeing seeing just
just nothing in this game you never
place the moves I am I expect yeah now
the exchange up
of course I lost a lot of time but well
I need to find some play lamu said she
simply didn't refute it no idea why a 3
was just winning I think no idea why
didn't go for that
yeah this is just the exchange zero
compensation I think yeah okay wants to
you can get some something going with
Bishop with the bishop
not sure should I return the exchange I
can just drop this one back
check
try to get for the counter tick maybe
you can draw now at just 99 seconds left
so check check check check check yeah
we'll get another absolutely unnecessary
time loss Jack Jack Jack yeah I simply
lost too much time here thinking about
the lost position and then he played
like a complete [ __ ] what can I say
just day 3 and resigns I just just loose
material on let's check quickly with the
computer oh no actually not okay
what's the idea be five or something
just let me check quickly
so we can turn to the position here
I'm still don't get what what happens on
a 384 say not in the best of formic acid
okay let's go for another came